an article reads that jay reiff was
sitting in his pickup truck
on the outskirts of las vegas when he
answered a phone call
that would permanently alter his life a
man from the federal government was on
the line and told him
that the loan he had taken out so his
son and daughter could go to school
go to college had come due the monthly
payment america
was 12 hundred dollars
rife said i thought i was going to pass
out
who was only making 13 an hour as a
maintenance worker
i hung up the phone and just kind of sat
there
for an hour trying to figure out what
was i going to do
he didn't want to tell his wife tina
hoping to protect her from the
possibility
of being plunged into poverty but it was
a secret he could keep i think we both
sat and cried
for a while over it said jay now 64
years old uh the couple originally at
forty thousand dollars took out
has uh has snowballed in the last 18
years with interest rates as high as
8.5 percent their bill now
stands at more than a hundred thousand
dollars
they couldn't afford it so they
negotiated with the federal government
to get it down to 733 dollars a month
still that payment is more than a
mortgage
and it doesn't cover the interest so the
amount owed
has continued to grow
and this bothers me man as i was reading
this
ken okay there's a lot of things in this
article that
which is very very frustrating to me but
here's the thing that really
really bothered me check this out
america part of what pushes up those
numbers
are the government's interest rates
which are higher than
private banks they've averaged more than
seven percent seven percent over the
past decade
over seven on top of that on top of the
seven
america the government charges parents
an additional fee
of more than four percent of the total
loan
and the terms are relatively unforgiving
the government makes money
off of parent plus loans according to
the congressional
budget course like this are you ready
for this
uh more than 200 000 families who made
less than
40 000 a year listen to this folks
okay took out a parent plus loan in
2016.
this was an increase of 33 percent
from 2008 so we're talking about
eight years 33 percent more took out
these loans and these are folks that are
making less than 40
000 a year and this speaks to what i was
saying in the last segment if you missed
it
there is a marketing message ao that
that has
has been a combined effort between state
and federal government yes pushing this
message
that higher education is the best way to
success
it is the way to the american dream yeah
and
that is not the case it's not
is it a way sure is it the way
no it's not the way let me tell you what
has thrived
during the coronavirus pandemic yes
the trades come on man come on and by
the way we're not just talking about
plumbers and electricians and welders
and carpenters as individuals we're
talking about
businesses in the trades that employ
people
and it is the small business
man and woman yes the small businesses
in the trades
ao that drive our
economy and again i mentioned this my
good friend mike grove from dirty jobs
i've interviewed him several times he's
the one that showed me the poster when
he was actually in high school
in the 70s a poster was put up in the
guidance counselor's office where it
showed
two men in the poster on one side it was
like a split screen on one side
was a man in a a young man
in a uh graduation gown and
a you know the hat and he's got his
diploma in his arm and he's
smiling as though the world is at his
feet and underneath him it said work
smart
yeah yeah yeah on the other side of the
poster is a man
in overalls dirt on his face and on his
coveralls and
uh a big giant wrench
over his shoulder and he looks as though
the world
has beaten him down and underneath him
it said
not work hard work smart not work hard
and this is the marketing message that
began to take over
and so it was here's what parents do
when they see that i'm not a good parent
if johnny or susie doesn't go to college
we are less than if we go to the
neighborhood block party or the picnic
or the cocktail party and they say
what's junior doing and you go well
junior's studying to be a welder in the
trade school you're supposed to be
ashamed of that no
it became a message that well juniors at
the state college
yes studying to become successful
when junior was probably partying and
not studying
yes and now when college education
became the way that states
get federal funding and more jobs and
endowments became
in the billions of dollars and higher
education became
big business now i'm about to step on
all kinds of toes
then the cost of education went up thus
the price of student loans went up in
the sense that the government went oh we
can make money on both ends of this deal
yes and so now we're gonna put out loans
for parents and
big government comes in and says you too
can have the american dream
if you borrow this money from us and pay
us back
and then we see how out of control it's
gotten you know the numbers better than
i do
and now we're saying well we're going to
forgive these loans because it's the
right thing to do except that
the american people have paid well
because their taxes for those loans so
we got ourselves a big giant cultural
lie that we need to deal with
that college is the only way to success
that's just a big bunch of crap
i mean what we're seeing right now we're
not saying that college
uh doesn't help you become successful no
but if you do it the wrong way
your dream now becomes a nightmare but
if you do it and you don't need it what
are we doing
oh it's really good for junior to go and
experience life yes on campus and
meet people and learn how to party
no if your kid doesn't need the degree
if it's not the
only way or the best way why are you
sending your kid to college i'm going to
tell you something right now
i think it's nonsensical that's what i
think it's not a rite of passage
it's a cultural thing it's a right
it's a status is what it is it's like
huh our kid went to college
big freaking deal if one of the coleman
kids comes to me and says dad i know
what the path is
and college isn't it i'm going to check
out the path we're going to talk through
it
we're going to make sure it's in their
sweet spot and then i'm going to go go
baby go go
because while all your friends are
partying and eating ramen noodles and
racking up
debt you're making money and you're way
ahead folks we got to wake up man
because we got families that are
crippled crippled crippled financially
because of this cultural
garbage this family are now
60 he's 63 years old the mother is six
three as well yeah
no in this article they're saying uh we
are
disabled can no longer work and we do
not have health insurance
because we just have to make these loan
payments
and to me that is so frustrating and
that is why i love what you're doing
teaching people how to find their sweet
spot
then see what's the best route to get to
that sweet spot but you wrote a number
one best-selling book that every parent
who's sitting there going okay ken maybe
i'll be open to this
but i really think my kid needs to go to
school well would you at least buy
anthony's book debt free degree
anthony o'neil dot com dave ramsey.com
because he actually shows you how your
kid
can go to school if they need the degree
and not be overwhelmed
and here's the thing that that when i
was reading this whole article which was
a little frustrating part for me was it
was this
it was like hey they went to in-state
school well okay they couldn't afford
it well then you should have went to
community college okay
there are options to where you can be
successful and not rack up debt when it
comes
nobody cares where your degree is when
was the last time you went to the doctor
and before he saw you said i'm sorry
could you please show me your diploma
please nobody does it